Danner:
We got a dead body and a
lot of people to talk to.
What's your name,
you fine as He-
-Sebastian.
-Travis.
[phone buzzes]
Look who decided to call.
Danner:
Has there been another murder?
Ha!
Uh, actually...
[screams]
[falling]
Hit me with that Aniq
rom-com sequel.
This is not a sequel.
♪ "It's My Party"
by Leslie Gore ♪
Aniq:
Number one suspect is the
bride, Zoe's sister.
♪ Cry if I want to ♪
Grace didn't do it.
Danner:
We got a dead body and a whole
lotta people to talk to.
What's your name?
You fine as hell.
-Sebastian.
-Travis.
♪ You would cry too ♪
Danner:
We'd like to hear your accounts
of what happened.
I like to call them
your mind movies.
Travis:
She was all trouble.
And for the record-
Travis:
the case wasn't the only thing
that was hard.
Oh, God.
Aniq:
Everyone here had a motive.
I have many tales to tell.
Actually, maybe you could just
start from the beginning of the
wedding.
I'm a searcher.
Okay.
Edgar is a crumb.
And Grace knows that I'm-
What's that?
Pretty handy with a broom.
That was a broom.
That's how I can tell you've
never swept before.
It's like a lightsaber.
Happy birthday!
Oh, it's actually my Adoption
Day. I don't know when I was
born.
♪ Cry if I want to ♪
This looks delicious.
That's potpourri.
Ah, Bon Appetit.
You know you're eating air
freshener.
Mmm!
[camera flashing]
Aniq:
Anyone could have done it.
My mother says hello.
Edgar:
She wanted to be here, but she
was busy with silence and alcohol.
♪ It's my party,
and I'll cry if I want to ♪
Let us raise a toast
to the happy couple.
Travis:
This whole thing is so much more
complex than you guys realize.
♪ Cry if I want to ♪
We all have our secrets.
[growling]
Yeah!
Well, I think it's pretty clear-
-We got our guy.
-That's not our guy.
What did you say? Got or not?
Not.
What?
♪ You would cry too,
if it happened to you ♪
Well, I know who killed Edgar.
[whispering]
When rich white people whisper,
it's never a good thing.